we have a professional agreement for  adequate minimum wages in europe  and that's a big win for the shop  assistants for the partial deliverers  for the agricultural workers and all  those workers who do not get the pay  they deserve prices explodes  for energy bills for the rents and for  the groceries  people struggle to get entrance meats  and every worker deserves new clothes  every now and then  or a holiday  everyone deserves a decent standard of  living the negotiations have been  challenging  but we succeeded in striking the rights  balance  europe is now taking a u-turn with this  european law we reduce wage inequalities  and give the europe lowest paid workers  the well-deserved pay rise  [Music]